now I'm 48 and a mom of two girls and it
all comes full circle when did you get
your first tattoo and I'm like hey
you don't get to know about that I'm
like
13. did you really yeah
so I totally fully understand your
relationship thank you thank you I love
illegal tattooing thank you oh yeah no
by the way it's not something I really
recommend this this person who gave us a
tattoo it was like in somebody's house
of course like ordered it online of
course and he was like I've been
practicing on oranges I think I'm ready
and
legitimate to me do you still like the
tattoo it's horrendously ugly
head right
and it's named shock I should have known
everything
it doesn't even look it was supposed to
be a blue well first I got these flowers
wait where did you put it where's your
first here mine's here